[Music]
[Music]
after two months in a house i'm back out
on the road
it's been a week and a half of getting
back into the swing of things but i'm
really happy to be out here
during the last few days of the house
sit a good friend from washington rolled
through and we all went camping together
with the dogs
turns out jack loves camping and i was
reminded of just how much i miss
being outdoors and waking up with the
sun
[Music]
i have no record
[Music]
proud
[Music]
but i have you
[Music]
you have me honey
[Music]
got upsetting now
[Music]
you're gonna come camping with us you
excited you got your camping gear
you got your backpack this is jack every
time we leave the house
he like insists on coming and we'll
block the door
jack i gotta get out check gotta get out
jack
[Music]
jack jack oh my gosh this little bandit
snuck out
he here's your knows sir
yeah we're going camping
summer breaks
winter storms
i don't mind
getting known
you have me honey
[Music]
[Music]
all the way
dog toys are expensive i'm taking it
oops
[Laughter]
hmm
at least the fire
[Music]
a few days after the camping trip we
picked jen and colin up from the airport
they've spent the last two months in
nepal and we're just now coming home
after summoning mount everest together
how does it feel
every summer you guys killed it oh so
nice to be home
and you summoned it together that's
incredible top of the world together
so rad we said goodbye to jack jenna and
colin
packed up our rigs and headed back onto
the road i
just pulled off on the side of the road
and it's so loud
i'm like not used to all this traffic
noise i'm used to
quiet calm house but yeah
this is gonna take a little bit of
adjusting this is actually
like the first time that i've been in a
place for so long two whole months and
now i am
getting on the road again and it almost
feels kind of weird like
having to remember a lot of things like
okay i need to figure out where i'm
gonna sleep tonight
and try not to get too dirty because
i'm not sure what i'm gonna shower again
i just drove through jackson to get
groceries and to drop off my propane
tank to get filled
but jackson is like a zoo it's funny
being here for two
months it's been like a ghost town and
now it's
just all of a sudden slammed and there's
so many tourists i'm probably gonna hang
around here for a little bit because
it's so beautiful
nate and i lucked out and found a great
camping spot in the bridger teton
national forest
we stayed for five days which was the
perfect amount of time to relax and
readjust to living on the road
i was even able to meet up with a friend
i haven't seen since i was living in
hawaii
15 years ago which is one of the things
i love most about being on the road
there's so many opportunities to
randomly meet up with amazing people
i just took a two-hour nap and it's 7 30
just went and walked through the woods
and it's super hazy outside
[Applause]
i'm gonna try to get back on the
schedule of being on the road so
let me see if i can go to bed kind of
early tonight and hopefully wake up for
sunrise tomorrow
[Music]
buzz along my
[Music]
[Music]
we made one last stop in jackson to drop
off some donations
which is something i do pretty often now
that i live in a van and have limited
space
also we were able to get both the first
and second doses of the pfizer vaccines
during our stay in jackson
which was a huge relief because we
really didn't want to drive all the way
back to washington just for that
so we left wyoming feeling pretty well
prepared to hit the road and hopefully
cross some borders this summer
but first montana that's the new
campsite
and this place is actually free which is
incredible
there's a reservoir out there you can go
swimming
and there's bathrooms so really stoked
[Music]
first morning in montana and i am making
banana pancakes
[Music]
isn't too bad here it's only three
dollars and 30 cents
[Music]
all right so i'm about an hour and 40
minutes away from the campsite
i don't really know anything about this
campsite except for what i found on
ioverlander
so it'll be interesting and my mirrors
have completely folded in because the
wind is so crazy right now
so i'm actually having an issue with
them because something
happened with my system um and like the
power mirrors need to be reset
i went to a dealership and they said
they can't access
the control panel because it has a build
over it this panel
comes off so i can change the brake
light but the control panel is back here
and that's a solid piece of wood and
there's a chance even if they access it
the wiring
for the mirrors goes all the way up here
which will be
pretty much impossible to access so
i have been doing a really janky
self-repair here as you can see i've got
gaffer tape
and honestly it's been holding since
durango
well actually san diego is where it
started and that gaffer tape's been
holding
um but it just folded in so i
am pulled off on the side of the highway
and i gotta go fix it so i have to try
to
sit in the driver's seat and reach over
and like manipulate the mirror so that
it's in a good position before i tape it
because it'll be stuck there
so i just re-taped it and it's extra
janky this time
um but i just kind of want to get a move
on um
and if it doesn't hold i'll probably
have to pull off at a hardware store and
get some metal plates
to hold it but hopefully this will work
you can see it i've got my bike back
here and i've got
my firewood down here my gaffer tape
here in case i need it
the van's all put together i'm a hot
mess
i still have another hour and a half to
go
and uh great thing about having a toilet
in the van i just
pull over go to the bathroom don't have
to go out of my way but you guys it's so
hot outside
i'm like dying so
it's really nice when i'm driving with
the air conditioning it'll be
interesting to see what it feels like at
this campsite hopefully i can find a
shady spot hopefully i can find a spot
at all
i have no idea what to expect here um
and hopefully the road's not too gnarly
but i guess we'll find out
so far so good must be holding
oh my god the tape just came off
well guys it's not looking good so far
the tape already peeled off in both
spots
and i haven't even gotten out of the
road one thing i have been struggling
with since getting on the road
is just prioritizing work
because once again a lot of my time and
energy
tension is moving towards where am i
going to sleep where am i going to
shower
do i have enough food do i have enough
gas do i have water all those things and
it's kind of hard to prioritize work
emails and projects photography shoots
video um i really wanted to do a van
tour this week and that's kind of been
put on the back burner
just as i work out other logistics for
things
but it's still top of my list i thought
i'd throw this vlog together
and just kind of update you guys on
where i am and honestly i want to do
more videos like this because
this is what my life is actually like
you know it's sometimes it's just super
chaotic and frazzled and i'm just moving
from point a to point b
living life
[Music]
which is awesome and
i just saw some people walking their dog
some of their fellow van lifers out here
[Music]
so i made it to camp and i'm pretty sure
i got the last campsite here
i'm excited this place looks awesome i
just took out my bike
unfolded it and locked it up to the van
so i got a u-lock that connects to the
van down here
and then i have this lock here so it's
locked up pretty good it's accessible
and
gives me a lot more space inside the van
i got the van up on blocks to make it
flat and
i've got a campfire
good morning just made my bed
this is the view outside it's gonna be
such a beautiful day
[Music]
[Music]
is just like